[Music]
very few sony productions have had as
much hype in the last two years as venom
let there be carnage based on the title
which sounds very appealing to splatter
fans everyone assumed that the film
would not be approved for younger
audiences much to the frustration of
many fans the motion picture association
of america or mpaa for short announced
that the movie would in fact be given a
13 plus age rating thus there can be no
talk of brute force or rampaging carnage
in the upcoming film on the other hand
this is hardly surprising since sony has
been relatively consistent with its age
rating so far the predecessor received
the same rating so anyone hoping that
venom let there be carnage would fall in
the footsteps of the joker as the most
successful oriented film of all time
wasn't for a big disappointment dc's
competitors didn't have much success
with similar movies either see the
suicide squad or birds of prey venom let
there be carnage will be released in
news theaters on october 15th 2021
the resident evil video game series has
been thrilling horror fans around the
globe for over 25 years there's also a
film series starring milovich although
it tends to be avoided by hardcore fans
due to its high action and lower horror
content however the upcoming reboot
resident evil welcome to raccoon city is
meant to address precisely this target
group as the remake deliberately goes in
a considerably creepier direction this
is already proven by the first images
which show three exclusive scenes from
the film among others you can see kyo
scodelario as claire radfield tom hopper
ass albert wesker nathan dale says brett
vickers hannah john cayman as jill
valentine marina mazipa asked lisa
trevor and last but not least robbie mal
as chris radfield the hub of the events
will of course be the infamous spencer
mansion which already terrified fans
back in the first video game
particularly the appearance of lisa
trevor kostester within the fan
community after all the girl who is only
14 years old is the terrifying result of
a failed umbrella experiment her
presence is also a good sign for it
means that the setting of the original
is being adhered to the reboot resident
evil welcome to raccoon city will be
released in theaters on november 24th
2021
fans of top gunmaver account mission
impossible 7 need to stand strong
because paramount has once again decided
to postpone the two movies starring tom
cruise much to the annoyance of many
fans of the 59 year old is not only a
matter of a few weeks but several months
in fact paramount is pursuing a special
strategy as it recently announced that
it would not be releasing any more films
in 2021 for top gun maverick the
memorial day weekend has been set as the
target release in the us which starts on
may 28 2022 that would originally have
been the date for mission impossible 7
which is why it is also being delayed by
several months in order to have enough
time between the two tome cruise movies
mission impossible 7 will now be pushed
to september 30th 2022 thus making it
more than a year away do you sympathize
with paramount's decision or would you
prefer the company to follow the example
of its competitors and release the movie
sooner feel free to let us know your
opinion in the comments
disney's jungle cruise is currently
playing in theaters and with nearly 190
million in box office earnings it's not
doing too badly considering it's
released during the pandemic the crux of
the matter however is that the film cost
a whopping 200 million us dollars to
produce which is rather a lot of money
nevertheless disney decided to make a
second part where the reason is clear at
the present time 190 million us dollars
in revenue is really not bad and on top
of that with jungle cruise they have
finally managed to land another success
in the domain of live action adventures
the company will be particularly
distressed at the thought of the
large-scale national treasure franchise
with nicolas cage given that all in all
it was a disaster of course the success
of jungle cruise is largely due to the
excellent performance of dwayne johnson
emily blunt which is why it comes as no
surprise that both of them will be back
for the second part nor will there be a
change when it comes to directing as jon
calacera will once again be in charge it
has not been said yet when exactly we
will be able to see frank wolff and his
companion duck dildy hooton again on the
big screen but we will keep you updated
john favreau's animated film the lion
king was a huge success in 2019 now it
is supposed to continue with a prequel
to disney's remake as we learned a few
days ago there are already first cast
members to talk about according to the
us magazine deadline aaron pierre will
dub mufasa while calvin harrison jr will
provide the voice for his hostile
brother scar the aforementioned jon
favreau will no longer be involved in
the project however since moonlight
director barry jenkins has been signed
on for the prequel together with jeff
nathanson who also wrote the screenplay
for the 2019 film they soon want to
deliver worthy prequel to the hit movie
after all it's the 7th most successful
movie of all time with box office takens
of 1.6 billion us dollars what exactly
the story will be about is still unclear
at this point the only thing that is
certain is that the breathtaking
animation technology of the original
will be used again unfortunately the
release date of the lion king prequel is
not yet known
in recent weeks the gossip factory has
been working overtime on the expandables
4. after seven years since the last part
it's now clear that there will be no
spin-offs for individual characters as
for example jason statham's league
christmas but a proper fourth part this
is also being confirmed by the hollywood
reporter which has already published the
first cast members of part 4. thus
returning to the movie are sylvester
stallone as barney ross jason statham as
lee christmas dove lundgren as gunner
jensen and randy couture as toll road so
far so good but much more exciting are
the new editions who are no strangers to
the entertainment business on the one
hand there is former transformers star
megan fox us rep legend curtis jackson
aka 50 cent and martial artist tony yeah
according to the hollywood reporter
jason statham's character lee christmas
will not receive a spin-off but he's
expected to be given a much stronger
focus on the female cast side megan fox
will take the lead role the exact
release date for the expandables 4 is
still unclear but we do not expect it to
be released before the end of 2022 given
that filming starts in october
october 16 2021 is the day the dc fandom
will be held again the now second
edition of the event which was
established as a counterpart to san
diego comic-con due to last year's
pandemic promises some new footage this
year as well the most exciting thing is
probably the announcement of a new the
batman trailer which will be the second
of its kind to be shown at the
convention about time too since the dc
blockbuster will be released in march of
next year in addition we can look
forward to exclusive insights into other
a-list films from warner brothers
besides the batman there will be new
footage of the flash black adam aquaman
and the lost kingdom as well as shazam
fury of the gods plus there will
reportedly be a farewell tribute to the
series of supergirl as it will not be
continued after six seasons now for the
series that started in 2019 called bad
woman there will also be new insights
just like for the flash series the
second dc fandom will take place on
october 16th 2021 so if you are looking
for specific topics you definitely
shouldn't miss the live stream
in the meantime if you want to hear or
see more about the mcu instead we highly
recommend the latest original recording
all the most recent news on black
panther wakanda forever if you're more
into the old franchises though don't
miss the most recent and final trailer
for the upcoming james bond no time to
die on our channel
[Music]
uh
[Music]